so with the iphone se on pre-order still
you may be on the fence do i go for an
iphone se or do i go for an iphone 13
mini we got both in our hands here's our
thoughts now the iphone sc we should
call it the retro edition not the
special edition should be called iphone
re because it is basically an iphone 8
design but it's got the a15 bionic chip
in it 4.7 inch display touch id all that
stuff with it but
it comes at a very good price point i
mean this is pretty much the most packed
iphone you have for under a thousand
singapore dollars the iphone 13 mini is
almost double the price depending on the
storage capacity but you get a lot more
in this phone so here's our thoughts if
you just want to browse the web take a
couple photos you're not really into
video that per se or shooting video and
you're just capturing moments but you
just want a nice phone that's easy to
use it's fast decent battery life go for
the sc if you want those video
capabilities cinematic modes you want
the two cameras on this wide ultra wide
you want the bells and whistles of the
iphone 13 series go for the mini those
are our thoughts on these two phones